Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour tout le monde.
On va parler de maths.
Qui connaît le test d’association
des mots de Jung ?
Personne ? Vous allez voir,
le concept est très simple.
Je vais vous dire un mot stimulus
et vous devez me répondre la première
chose qui vous passe par la tête.
Si je vous dis par exemple « TED »,
vous me répondez...
Ok, ça va être long.
(Rires)
Si je vous dis - on fait
un deuxième test - « Fromage »,
vous me dites...
(Public murmure)
Très bien.
On a avancé et maintenant :
« Mathématiques », vous me dites...
(Public murmure)
Voilà, très bien.
J’ai fait le test -
En bon scientifique,
j’ai fait l’expérience avant.
Quand j’ai demandé aux gens :
« Qu’est-ce que vous dites
quand on dit mathématiques ? »
Ils m’ont répondu ça.
Et puisque...
Puisque je suis un bon scientifique,
j’ai donné de ma personne.
Et moi aussi, j’ai fait le test.
Ce que j’ai répondu, c’était :
intime, créatif et social.
Pourquoi je prétends que les mathématiques
sont une discipline qui est très intime ?
Parce que je pense que ce n'est
pas du tout impersonnel.
Les émotions et la subjectivité ont
toute leur place en mathématiques.
Pourquoi les émotions ?
Tout simplement parce que
c’est un moteur très puissant.
On a besoin de notre envie,
de notre curiosité,
peut-être de notre frustration même,
pour avoir l’énergie de pousser plus loin
notre compréhension des choses.
Et c'est vrai pour les mathématiques.
En plus, les émotions, et par exemple
la capacité d’abstraction,
elles viennent du même endroit, elles
viennent du plus profond de notre être.
Ce sont des choses que l’humanité a
développées tout au long de son histoire,
comme le langage ou l’écriture.
Et ce sont un peu nos super-pouvoirs
pour décrire et ressentir
le monde qui nous entoure.
Donc il faut arrêter d'opposer
raisonnement rationnel et émotion.
Ce sont deux choses qui se complètent.
Pourquoi subjectivité ?
Voici un exemple, ce sera plus parlant.
Prenons un type de subjectivité
qui est le goût esthétique.
En mathématiques, il y a l’algèbre,
la géométrie, l’analyse,
la théorie des graphes, la théorie des
jeux, la probabilité, les statistiques.
Il y a une variété incroyable
de mathématiques.
Je vous avouerai que je n’apprécie pas
tous les types de mathématiques.
Il y a des mathématiciens
qui aiment les formes,
d'autres qui vont aimer les nombres.
Moi, j’aime décrire le monde
qui m’entoure,
la physique du monde qui m’entoure,
à l’aide de mathématiques.
Donc, on ne peut pas tout aimer en maths.
Et je vais vous dire quelque chose,
je suis certain que vous ne détestez
pas tout, en mathématiques.
il y a une variété incroyable
de mathématiques,
et d’ailleurs il y a aussi une variété
incroyable de façons de la pratiquer.
Si vous prenez un enfant
de deux ans, par exemple,
il apprend les concepts
de formes en jouant.
Si vous prenez un enfant un peu plus âgé,
qui apprend à compter, que fait-il ?
Il essaie de compter
le plus loin possible.
Un adulte, peut-être qu’il voudra faire
des maths son hobby, ou son métier.
Finalement, on fait les mathématiques
de façon très différente,
en fonction de son âge, de son pays,
de l’époque, du lieu.
Il y a autant de mathématiques
que de personnes.
Et chaque personne a un attachement
particulier à ces mathématiques
et c’est en ça que je pense
qu’elles sont intimes.
Quel est le point commun entre toutes
ces façons de faire des mathématiques ?
Le point commun,
c’est qu’elles sont toutes créatives.
On va faire une expérience.
Fermez les yeux, ne vous inquiétez pas -
je vois qu’il y a des gens réticents.
Fermez les yeux et imaginez
une personne créative.
D’accord ?
Alors, que voyez-vous ?
À mon avis, il y a des gens
qui voient une peintre devant sa toile.
Il y a d’autres qui voient un écrivain,
un danseur, une compositrice.
Vous les voyez dessiner, écrire,
raturer, tester, expérimenter,
un processus foisonnant.
Alors maintenant, gardez les yeux fermés.
Ne vous inquiétez pas,
personne n’essaie de faire vos poches.
Gardez les yeux fermés et imaginez-moi
en train de faire des mathématiques.
Et là, à mon avis -
(Rit) il y a eu un rire.
À mon avis, vous imaginez que
je suis en train d’enchaîner des calculs
à longueur de journée
de façon mécanique, robotique.
Il y a des formules, il y a des symboles.
Je vais utiliser un gros mot :
il y a peut-être un théorème
qui se passe quelque part.
Mais en fait, ce que vous imaginez
quand vous faites ça -
vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux - j’en vois
qui pensent : Ah c’est cool ! (Rit) -
ce que vous imaginez quand vous faites ça,
vous imaginez le résultat
des mathématiques,
pas le processus qui mène à celui-ci.
Maryam Mirzakhani, la première
femme à recevoir la médaille Fields,
la récompense la plus
prestigieuse de notre domaine,
disait : «Plus que la question,
c’est la façon de répondre
qui est importante en mathématiques. »
C’est le processus qui mène à la réponse.
Et ce processus, en mathématiques
comme ailleurs, est fait de tâtonnement,
d’innovation, d’essais et d’erreurs.
En fait, quand vous pensez à moi
en train de faire des mathématiques,
si vous y repensez plus tard,
pensez plutôt à quelqu’un qui est
face à un tableau de ce type.
Il y a des ratures et des dessins.
C’est exactement la même chose que ce que
vous imagineriez pour un ou une artiste.
C’est juste en effet, mes outils
ne sont pas un pinceau et de la peinture,
ce sont des idées et un concept.
Voilà.
Alors certes, je ne vais pas
dire le contraire,
après avoir inventé ma preuve,
après avoir inventé mon idée,
il faut que je la traduise en formules.
Mais est-ce si différent d’une
compositrice qui a inventé une mélodie ?
À un moment, il faut bien
qu’elle la couche sur la partition.
L’important, c’est
qu’elle ait créé la mélodie.
Une fois qu’on accepte que les maths
sont une discipline créative,
quelque chose d’intéressant se passe :
ce qui est vu comme une contrainte,
devoir suivre par exemple des règles,
devoir suivre un formalisme,
ça devient au contraire
une source de créativité.
Les mathématiques vous offrent
un espace de liberté incroyable,
un monde à lui tout seul,
où vous pouvez vous balader librement
en 8 ou en 24 dimensions.
Dernier point, on a dit que les
mathématiques étaient aussi sociales.
Alors pourquoi -
fermons les yeux et refaisons un test,
ceux qui avaient oublié de les ouvrir,
c’est bon, continuez comme ça -
donc vous fermez les yeux,
et essayez d’imaginer des mathématiques
en train de se faire.
Donc là, normalement,
si je n’ai pas trop mal fait mon job,
vous imaginez une personne
devant un tableau,
noir, avec des dessins, des ratures, etc.
Partie «Tableau noir, Ratures, dessins»,
un bon point pour vous.
Une personne seule devant ;
très mauvais point.
Vous pouvez rouvrir
les yeux, c’est bon. (Rit.)
En fait, il faut imaginer deux
mathématiciens ou mathématiciennes,
peut-être trois, peut-être même plus,
il faut imaginer des gens qui confrontent
leurs idées, qui donnent des exemples,
des contre-exemples,
qui tentent de convaincre
l’autre personne.
Les mathématiques, elles passent
d’abord par le langage.
Je ne travaille qu’en collaboration,
je n’arrive pas à travailler seul.
Je vais vous raconter la genèse d’une
de mes plus belles découvertes à mon avis.
Comme toute histoire de mathématiques,
elle commence par du café.
Donc, on était en train de boire
un café avec mon meilleur ami
et aussi collègue très proche
qui s’appelle Vincent.
On parlait de rien essentiellement
et il me présentait une idée
qu’il avait eue, un argument assez joli,
mais qui ne menait nulle part.
Moi, je me suis tout de suite figé.
Parce qu’en fait, cette chose
qu’il venait de me dire,
c’était exactement ce qui me manquait
pour faire fonctionner un argument
que j’essayais de faire fonctionner
depuis quatre ans.
Ça faisait quatre ans que j’étais bloqué
et là, autour d’un café,
boum, il me le donne.
J’étais figé,
je lui dis que c’est incroyable,
que mon argument va pouvoir
fonctionner avec son idée.
Puis là, il me dit : «Mais attends,
cet argument, cette idée -»
En fait, il n’a pas fait tout à fait ça,
il a commencé à sauter de joie.
«Mais qu’est-ce qu’il se passe,
Vincent ?»
Il me dit que c’est incroyable,
les deux choses ensemble permettent
de démontrer ultra facilement
l’un des résultats les plus difficiles
de notre domaine.
Comment ça ?
Il s’est avéré
que la combinaison des idées a donné
une preuve en moins d’une page
d’un argument qui demandait des dizaines
de pages à être prouvé avant.
Cet argument, c’était un point-clé
de tous les cours
sur ce qu’on appelle
la théorie de la percolation -
ne pensez pas que je suis
obsédé par le café -
mais il se trouve que là,
il y a un point de coïncidence.
Et donc du coup,
eh bien, ça a simplifié,
ça a changé complètement la façon même
d’enseigner la discipline.
Une page au lieu de dizaines de pages.
Et c'était un merveilleux moment
de découverte partagée.
Ni lui ni moi n’aurions jamais
pu découvrir cette preuve.
C'est une preuve qu'on partage.
Je dois admettre que je vous
ai fait des petites cachotteries
en vous disant qu’il n’y avait que 3 mots
que j’associais naturellement aux maths.
Il y en a un quatrième.
Ce sera notre petit secret.
C'est que les mathématiques,
elles sont inclusives.
Dans quel sens ?
Si vous pensez intime,
créative et sociale,
vous imaginez bien que ça fait repenser
quelles sont les personnes
qui ont accès aux mathématiques.
Ce que je prétends, c’est que
tout le monde a accès aux mathématiques.
On l’a dit, les maths ne sont pas tant
une histoire de théorèmes ou de questions.
C'est un processus d'amélioration
de notre compréhension du réel.
C'est un processus partagé
de clarification du réel.
Et comme le disait Bill Thurston, un des
plus grands géomètres du 20e siècle :
«On conviendra que le monde
ne souffre pas d’un excès de clarté.»
Donc, la clarté partagée,
cette clarté qu’on a développée
tous ensemble finalement,
bien sûr, les mathématiciens,
au cours de toute l’histoire,
mais aussi les scientifiques
et aussi toute la population.
Ce n’est pas l’apanage de juste
quelques esprits, c’est l’apanage de tous.
Alors là, vous allez me dire :
« Non, là, je ne suis pas d’accord,
les maths, ce n’est pas pour moi.»
Mais est-ce si vrai que ça ?
Si je vous dis « Zéro ».
Tout le monde dans cette salle
a une idée de ce que c’est que zéro.
Pour reprendre Pythagore ou Thalès, qui
vous ont traumatisé avec leur théorème,
Pythagore et Thalès, dans l’Antiquité,
le zéro, ça n’existait pas.
Les plus grands esprits,
mais ils ignoraient ce que vous savez.
Au même titre, tout le monde comprend
ce qu’est un nombre négatif.
On a tous un compte en banque.
Eh bien, oui, il y a 200 ans,
pour la population,
un nombre négatif n’avait pas de sens.
C’était au-delà de ce qu’ils maîtrisaient.
Vous maîtrisez des choses que beaucoup
de gens ne maîtrisaient pas avant vous.
Ça bénéficie à tout le monde.
Tout le monde conviendra que nos
enfants doivent savoir lire et écrire.
Une chose à retenir à mon avis,
c’est que tous les enfants devraient être
aussi initiés à la démarche scientifique.
Et combien de jeunes filles et jeunes
garçons, au contraire, se disent :
«Mais moi, ma sensibilité, peut-être mon
envie de communiquer, mon intuition,
elles n’ont pas leur place
en mathématiques.»
Pire, combien de jeunes
se détournent des mathématiques
parce qu’on leur dit ça ?
Parce que la société,
leur entourage, leur dit ça.
Au contraire, il faudrait qu’on pousse
tous les enfants à avoir envie
de tester leur intuition mathématique
et leur capacité d’abstraction.
Car c’est l’un de nos super-pouvoirs
qui nous permet de décrire le monde.
Et en plus, c’est un merveilleux moyen
de faire preuve de liberté d’expression.
Alors, comment on fait ?
Première chose, remettons au centre
ce qui est connecté à la créativité,
c’est-à-dire l’erreur.
Il faut pouvoir dire à un enfant qu'il a
le droit de se tromper en mathématiques.
J’irais même plus loin,
c’est un devoir de se tromper.
En mathématiques, on ne progresse
qu'en se trompant.
Il ne faut pas avoir peur.
Comme disait Marie Curie :
«Dans la vie, il n’y a rien à craindre,
tout à comprendre.»
Vous allez me faire une promesse,
tout le monde, «promis».
Merci, ça me faire beaucoup
de clés de voiture ; parfait !
Donc promis, vous allez faire
la chose suivante
la prochaine fois que vous tombez
sur quelqu’un
qui a des difficultés en mathématiques,
pensez au nuage de mots suivants.
Plaidez le droit à l’erreur.
Dites-lui que c’est normal de se tromper,
de prendre du temps à comprendre.
Dites-lui de tester son intuition.
Dites-lui de communiquer avec les autres,
de s’autoriser des émotions,
d’être frustré ou au contraire heureux
par quelque chose en mathématiques.
Dites-lui de confronter ses erreurs
aux opinions des autres
et d’accepter aussi
les opinions des autres
et les erreurs des autres
pour essayer de les aider.
C’est comme ça qu’on apprend
et c’est comme ça qu’on a du plaisir.
C’est le cas de toutes les disciplines.
C’est le cas bien sûr
du sport ou de la musique.
Je pense que tout le monde associerait ce
genre de choses au sport et à la musique.
Mais c'est également vrai
des mathématiques.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)